jetzt alexander gauland für die afg
fraktion wir glauben der gestrigen
haushaltsrede von herr minister scholz
entnehmen zu dürfen dass ein
paradigmenwechsel in der regierung
stattgefunden hat der
bundesfinanzminister hat erklärt warum
es richtig ist dass deutschland aus der
kohleverstromung aussteigt und
mittelfristig dem verbrennungsmotor ag
sagt obwohl anders wohl massen weiß das
exakte gegenteil passiert weil wir es
können
anders gesagt das ist jetzt
wahrscheinlich die neue offizielle
parole nicht mehr wir schaffen das
sondern wir können das warum ist
napoleon nach moskau marschiert weil er
es konnte
warum hat weiter übrig die mauer gebaut
weil er es konnte wir verstehen lieber
schulz deutsch sein heißt bekanntlich
eine sache und ihrer selbst willen
herr scholz hat es einmal mehr bestätigt
denn was bedeutet seine aussage anders
als wir würden auch dann aussteigen wenn
es nichts bringt aber was soll s
eigentlich bringen
für das weltklima ist deutschland keine
besonders relevante größe es geht hier
offenbar um symbolik 1945 waren wir der
teufel der welt heute wollen wir die
enge des planeten sein
das leuchtende vorbild
der chef der deutschen energie agentur
dena stephan kohler erklärte einmal
chinesischen managern das fördersystem
für die erneuerbaren energien
unter anderem führte er aus dass
deutsche windstromerzeugung sogar geld
für strom bekommen der nie produziert
wurde einer die chinesen so cool auch in
der pause sei zu ihm gekommen und habe
gesagt interessant aber kein vorbild sie
kennen alle den spruch meine damen und
herren das interessiert mich ungefähr so
viel als ob ein in china ein sack reis
umfällt im reich der mitte könnte sich
der komplementäre spruch einbürgern
das interessiert mich ungefähr so viel
als ob in deutschland ein kohlekraftwerk
vom netz gehen meine damen und herren
die erste hälfte dieser
legislaturperiode liegt hinter uns an
solchen zeit schwellen ist es üblich
zwischenbilanz zu ziehen ich frage wo
ist deutschland spitze und wo nicht
unangefochten europäischen spitze ist
deutschland beim strompreis und bei der
höhe der steuern sind wir immerhin
zweiter ganz weit vorn ist deutschland
bei der aufnahme von migranten und
absolute weltspitze bei deren
alimentierung allein das land hessen
zahlt für jeden unbegleiteten
jugendlichen flüchtling 8469 euro
monatlich aufs jahr gerechnet waren das
zuletzt 138 millionen
wir können hast einen spitzenplatz
belegt deutschland bei den zug
verspätungen bei den studienabbrechern
und wir liegen auch beim co2 ausstoß pro
kopf deutlich vor ländern wie schweden
und frankreich
weil die mehr atomstrom produzieren
spitze ist deutschland an den
steuereinnahmen überall durften wir
zuletzt lesen der staat haben
überschüsse erwirtschaftet meine damen
und herren hier muss ich einen einspruch
erheben
der staat erwirtschaftet gar nichts
dieses geld stammt von den ungefähr 15
millionen meist schon länger hier
lebenden tatsächlichen steuerzahler
die können das hat die regierung die
überschüsse zum anlass genommen den
bürgern mehr netto vom brutto zu lassen
und die steuern zu senken
die koalition konnte sich nicht einmal
auf die komplette abschaffung des soli
einigen
obwohl die rechtsgrundlage dafür
entfallen ist das ist nämlich der
eigentliche punkt weshalb der soli ganz
abgeschafft werden muss
dafür hat sie im ersten halbjahr wieder
mehr schulden gemacht
die verschuldung stieg nach angaben des
finanzministeriums innerhalb von sechs
monaten um mehr als 11 milliarden euro
für für infrastruktur für bildung für
die bundeswehr
die steigerung kommt unter anderem durch
einen im zusammenhang mit der
flüchtlingskrise gebildete rücklage
zustande meldete ntv am 6 august die
migration kostet bund und ländern
zweistellige milliardenbeträge
wir können das bleibt die feststellung
wo mir nicht spitze sind in der
mobilfunk abdeckung ist schon heute
gesagt worden die deutschland weltweit
auf rang 70 hinter albanien beim
internationalen mathematik und
naturwissenschaft test die mss sind wir
binnen weniger jahre von platz zwölf auf
rang 24 abgerutscht was bedenklich ist
mit einer physikerin an der spitze der
regierung
auf dem gebiet der künstlichen
intelligenz halten china die usa und
japan 75 prozent aller patente auf
deutschland entfallen nicht einmal drei
prozent
das heißt unsere anteile an der
künstlichen intelligenz und am co2
ausstoß gleichen sich allmählich an
meine damen und herren unser land ist
krank und es ist tief gespalten zwischen
ost und west zwischen forma
regierungslinie und böse opposition den
riss der sich durch unsere gesellschaft
zieht haben ja nun angeblich wir
verursacht und von göring eckardt aktion
auch mal ganz deutlich gesagt nur
verkehrt wir haben diesen riss nicht vor
sagt sondern wir bilden ihn ab er ist
gesellschaftlich da lassen sie mich kurz
auf die wahlen im osten ein
wenn man die zweitstimmen von sachsen
und brandenburg addiert ist die afg mit
hauchdünnem vorsprung stärkste partei
vor der cdu
das heißt das gros der wähler hat
bürgerlich konservativ gewählt aber sie
werden künftig linke regiert als vorher
liebe cdu der wahlkampf war ein spaltung
wahlkampf alle gegen die afd
30 jahre nach dem ende der ddr ist die
staatsfeindliche hetze zurückgekehrt und
oppositionskritik die erste medien
pflicht wobei sich die find erklärung
und keineswegs nur an unsere adresse
richten frau kramp karrenbauers versuch
herrn maßen aus der cdu zu drängeln muss
ja als beispiel
auf der anderen seite gibt es wie damals
ergebenheitsadressen der
kulturschaffenden an die regierung schon
vor den wahlen 2009 10 sind im
haushaltsposten wie der einzelplan 04
der etat der bundeskanzlerin in
allerletzter minute aufgebläht worden zb
vervierfachte sich der etat des
bundesverbandes freie darstellende
künste ev auf wundersame weise die
führung dieses verbandes ist maßgeblich
beteiligt an der erklärung der vielen
einer bundesweiten initiative vor allem
staatlich geförderter bühnen und
institutionen die sich primär gegen die
afg gerichte dieses beispiel hier nur
als pars pro toto
die bundesregierung finanziert die
spaltung der gesellschaft entlang ihrer
willkürlichen gezogenen linien die
interessante frage laute darf sie das
überhaupt ein gutachten des
wissenschaftlichen dienstes des
bundestages gibt eine klare antwort die
im staat bleibe es zwar unbenommen
freiheitlich-demokratische
wertvorstellungen zu verbreiten
derartige aktionen dürfen sich aber
nicht gezielt gegen bestimmte parteien
richten
dies wäre ein verstoß gegen die
staatliche neutralitätspflicht wir
werden darauf zurück
meine damen und herren sie kennen
sicherlich alle den begriff reptilien
form also aus dem haushalt abgezweigte
mittel die zur politischen einflussnahme
verwendet werden
er stammt von otto von bismarck der 1869
in einer rede die im dienst des
entthronten hessischen kurfürsten
arbeiteten agenten bösartige reptilien
land und deren bekämpfung aus einer
solchen kassel finanzierte frau
bundeskanzlerin nun ist sie nicht mehr
da wir begrüßen es ja immer wenn sie von
bismarck lernen wollen aber muss es
ausgerechnet sozusagen dieser punkt sein
wie deutschland im kleinen so ist europa
großen gespalten entlang derselben
bruchlinien zwischen ost und west
zwischen global ist 'nen und
partikularen zumindest für die
europäische politik ist die
migrationsfrage nach wie vor das
entscheidende thema es wird immer
deutlicher dass die verfestigung der
supranationalen eu strukturen und die
förderung der migration nach europa
zusammengehören es ist die zahl in
welche die nationen und nationalstaaten
genommen werden sollen
bis sie vor den europäischen demokratien
nur noch kontinent diese dörfer übrig
sind deswegen
wird jeder migrations kritiker
verteufelt deswegen werden
schlepperhilfe zu helden stilisiert
deswegen wird der öffentlichkeit
suggeriert man könnte die migrations
roten nicht schließen
über die verteilung der migranten
innerhalb der eu sollte sich nach dem
willen der bundeskanzlerin jedes
europäische land der massenzuwanderung
öffnen ist es erst einmal die relative
homogenität der europäischen völker
aufgelöst löst sich natürlich allmählich
auch der nationale zusammenhalt auf der
nationalstaat kann durch eine neue
internationale übernationale struktur
ersetzt werden das wird ohne eine
umerziehung der nach wie vor in ihren
nationalen klausuren lebenden denkenden
und fühlenden völker nicht funktionieren
diese umerziehung erleben wir täglich
sie beginnt in den schulen sie ergießt
sich über die werbung und endet abends
in den tagesthemen
wir können das weil ich
die briten spielen nicht länger mit weil
sie kein interesse daran haben das
idealistische deutschen über ihre
grenzen bzw ihre einwanderungspolitik
entscheiden
die polen und ungarn wissen aus ihrer
jüngsten geschichte dass es kein
vergnügen ist von fernen zentralen
diktate zu empfangen
die südosteuropäer haben historische
erfahrungen mit dem islam
die die einwanderung skeptisch machen
österreicher und italiener haben keine
lust mehr den transit zu organisieren
deshalb wird der praxis mit allen
mitteln boykottieren deshalb werden die
osteuropäer für die wahl zwischen
zuckerbrot und peitsche bestechung oder
isolation gestellt und deshalb werden
die falsch wähler in ostdeutschland mit
gift und galle über kübel meine damen
und herren ich kann nur wiederholen
sie werden akzeptieren müssen dass wir
dies nicht erzeugt haben
wir bilden ihnen nur ab ich bedanke mich